la guerra no da respiro las tácticas del
enemigo cambian y los hombres en el
frente no pueden parar su entrenamiento
cada gota de sudor durante la práctica
tiene un impacto positivo en el campo de
batalla
un hombre y una mujer bien entrenadas
pueden salvar muchas vidas después de
que el último pise el lazo el grupo debe
continuar el movimiento
cuando conoces las tácticas del enemigo
puedes prevenir neutralizarlo y
conseguir la victoria
la mayoría de estos hombres y mujeres
tenían vidas civiles antes de esa gran
invasión hace un año entonces tomaron
las armas y muchos de ellos se unieron a
las defensas territoriales que pasaron
más tarde a ser parte del ejército y
donde entonces están luchando en el
frente de batalla
estos hombres tuvieron que aprender lo
que hoy saben durante la Guerra esto se
opone a los soldados profesionales que
son entrenados por años Este es el caso
de andrei que era entrenador de fútbol
hasta hace un año
Entonces no podíamos imaginar que nos
pasaría en una semana o un mes al
comienzo pensábamos que la guerra no
duraría tanto como ha sido pero desde el
comienzo todos estábamos preparados
tanto moralmente como psicológicamente
todo esto lo han hecho consta de un gran
sacrificio
si no era nosotros Entonces quién
tenemos unas familias unos parientes una
nación y Alguien tiene que protegerlo
antes de la invasión Yuri era cantante
sus compañeros lo llaman Pavarotti
acepta recordar su vida pasada pero
evita extenderse
[Música]
en pocos días estos hombres regresarán
al frente de la región del sur de
saporilla ahora tienen más herramientas
para enfrentar al enemigo pero también
saben que no serán meses fáciles aquí se
espera una ofensiva rusa próximamente